[Music]
when the Mercedes SL debuted in 1963 it
had a tough act to follow
it was meant to be sporty but elegant
comfortable but fast all with the
familiar mercedes-benz quality and
reliability the SL was all that and
today as a classy car it still is it
swiftly acquired the nickname pagoda for
its concave hardtop mercedes-benz
presented its new SL series at the
Geneva International Motor Show as the
successor to both the legendary 300 SL
and the 190 SL known internally by its
chassis code w113 it was no domesticated
race car but more a sporty two-seater
car for street driving
[Music]
the pagoda was a hit especially in the
United States more than half the cars
produced were sold to America the ladies
were also charmed by this easy-to-handle
roadster
another reason for its appeal was the
new design vocabulary the w113 heralded
the demise of the Baroque contours of
its Mercedes forerunners and the advent
of sporty-er masculine lines while
preserving Mercedes typically genteel
elegance it was thoroughly modern but
not trendy the hardtop was standard on
every SL the roofs nicknamed pagoda
quickly evolved into a term of
endearment for the whole car in 1963 the
new Mercedes drew a lot of attention a
young French designer Paul Brock created
the new look and Mercedes design
language for the decade to come Mercedes
experts Multan lingonberry explains that
Paul Brock preferred graceful lines
compared to its predecessors the 300 SL
and 190 SL roadsters he very nearly
designed a compact car it was in fact a
compact sedan but had its own unique
style that seemed to glide along with
ease described in first poems the top up
or down the convertible cut a good
figure it's interior sacrifice another
Mercedes trademark opulence ease and
comfort
[Music]
the optional four-speed automatic
transmission was very popular with
buyers
[Music]
even if Mercedes gave the model a touch
of sportiness nowadays connoisseurs
appreciate the pagoda more for leisurely
drives and outings in the country
[Music]
now a pagoda in good condition will
fetch at least 60,000 euros the later
280s
were the most well engineered the
Mercedes 280 SL pagoda may not have been
as exciting as its Italian and American
competitors but it was robust and
reliable
[Music]